Red Dead Redemption too is coming next
spring but if you want a little taste of
it right now you should jump into GTA
online I'm Tony and this is your gun
sling and gamespot news update earlier
this week data miners found what
appeared to be red dead related content
in the GTA online files and Rockstar has
just confirmed a crossover mission and
weapon available today to get started
log in to GTA online and you'll receive
an email with a clue about a lost
frontier item cue the scavenger hunt
that eventually rewards you with a
double-action revolver complete a
headshot challenge with that and you'll
unlock the same gun for use in Red Dead
Redemption to the quest and weapon are
live right now as for Red Dead
Redemption 2 itself
that's slated for ps4 and Xbox one this
spring but no sooner than April 1st you
can certainly check out some trailers
and screenshots on GameSpot if you need
your frontier fix and while you're there
why not reminisce about everything 2017
had to offer with our countdown of the
top 10 games of the year
[Music]
[Music]